i am bringing the night pants nation
tour to minneapolis april 28 through the
30th june 4th los angeles at the world
famous troubadour one night only come on
out get tickets now for that if you're
local that's going to be a really fun
show get your tickets now
at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media again
every week every episode i'm grateful
thank you for your support thank you for
supporting this show thank you for
supporting the fans i know you guys
reach out to people and hit them up they
tell me all the time means the world
it's like your kids are you know going
over to somebody's house and spending
the night and coming back like your kid
was really well behaved i'm like really
mom all [ __ ] good makes me feel good
y'all subscribe to that youtube and hit
up the patreon honeydew with y'all if
you
love this show and you gotta have more
the honeydew with y'all is one of the
wildest [ __ ] shows on patreon right
now it's five bucks a month you sign up
for a year you're getting over a month
free and you're getting the honeydew a
day early ad free at no additional cost
all right we've heard the wildest
stories it's not going anywhere all
right night pants nation tour is coming
your way minneapolis april 28 through
the 30th all tickets for those shows and
all shows available at ryanstickler.com
all right that's the biz you know what
we do over here i was always telling you
we highlight the low lights and i always
say these are the stories behind the
storytellers and it's very exciting to
have this guest back
on the honeydew first time in this
studio ladies and gentlemen i said
gentlemen hold on
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
chelsea lynn y'all welcome back to the
honeydew girl i'm back two years later
thanks for having me thank you for being
here i can't wait to spend two years i
can't you know we were just talking
about that and i can't i mean that's the
be was were you right before the
pandemic then must have you must have
been the last two years blend for me
it's all blink all a blink but i was
just telling you like i've been on so
many podcasts and two years later i get
messages daily about me being on this
podcast i love that that blows me away
yes thank you for that thank you for
having me um
we're gonna get into some stuff here of
course but before we do please plug
everything you'd like all right uh well
i've got a new instagram since my other
one was deleted yeah we're gonna talk
about that okay we can talk about that
what else i mean chelsea lynn on tiktok
facebook i do heaven only fans there's
no porn on there so everybody listen
don't get too excited um you will see my
tits but it's more in a comedic way i
don't have like you know sexy pics on
there i do a weekly um
i'm calling it a tv show because it's a
[ __ ] tv show called tammy bangs
fully fully produced
full i mean we we work our asses off on
that tv show it's basically trailer
trash tammy
um is running a porn empire
okay and season one is already up
there's 17 episodes we're about to
launch season two you can go to
chelsealand.com trailer trash tammy's
like the hugh heff oh it is 20 22. yeah
yeah and this this um show can't be
posted anywhere else let's just you know
let's just say that it cannot be posted
anywhere else
especially with community guidelines
nowadays you can't post [ __ ]
um so yeah uh the only fans i'm i'm
going on tour in just a few days
let them know um most of the shows are
sold out so but
yeah if you're lucky enough to get a
ticket go to eatmytrash.com
that's my website
and uh come see a show i'm excited i'm
excited i'm excited for you you're
taking it to the next level you're
you've i've been watching your success
for a while you deserve it you're
blowing up the way you should thank you
shit's wild
um all right so speaking of wild there's
something i have to tell you i've been
telling you for a while that i want to
tell you your shirt right here trailer
trash tammy right there so you've done
how many calendars now three three three
topless three topless calendars
the one from i believe it was two years
ago that you gave me uh-huh um had a tit
on every
month and the back cover except for the
believe your cover was the only thing
that didn't have your titties and it was
it that for two years ago this one's
this year's this year's the one where
you asked me which titty was my favorite
yeah because they're different right
they are different they're very
different both beautiful the left one
was my favorite that's my favorite yeah
yeah the nipple sits a little higher but
go ahead i like it yeah it's like you
know it's it feels like it's looking you
know things are up you know yep um so
i'm here at the studio where your
calendar used to be prominently
displayed
in the studio and i'm here one day and i
bring my daughter in
my daughter was six at the time it was
about a year ago she doesn't come in
often she comes in a lot but um it was
sitting out this day i hadn't paid
attention and i turn around and i'm
doing something
and i turn back around i see my daughter
holding your calendar and she's in the
middle of that [ __ ] calendar
and she folds it up she doesn't say
anything she sets it down and she looks
at me and i swear to [ __ ] god
she goes dad
can you please put another image in my
head
oh my god and she's sick
can you please put another image in my
head [ __ ] anything else dad
and i said unicorns rainbows and i'm
laughing she's and she goes okay
okay and then she was good and i looked
that i go
you saw those huh and she's just shaking
her head yeah go listen to me stella
that'll bring a veteran those titties
will bring a veteran man to his knees
girl
this little girl with no bumps on her
chest dude she's clever potential and
what what could happen and she was like
oh
she's clever dude
oh my god another image of my head
anything else take your calendar
well she's already seen it might as well
put it back up
she's already seen it slap that thing
back up that [ __ ] killed me i was like
yes stella i said those those are some
titties god she's like anything else
just start popping off anything else
i've been wanting to tell you for so
long that's hilarious dude i love it
i love it get the calendar yeah i
haven't got a goddamn calendar yes get
yourself a calendar
yes okay so
this is your second time here with me
um you mentioned that after our first
recording
that something happened
yeah so not right after so i did the
podcast two years ago so this was like
i would say three four months ago tops
oh yeah so the pod had already been out
a year and a half at least
and um scrolling through instagram and i
get this dm that is
this
long i'm talking a mile long dm
and this lady starts off with um
hey chelsea i know this may be a very
weird message but
i used to date your dad and we had
gotten into my childhood the last pod
talked about my dad how he's really not
in my life first dead body if i remember
first dead body two years later still
haven't ran into another one but exactly
and um she she goes off and my parents
had me when they were 17. damn yeah yeah
so she said um she said i dated your dad
when we were 17
and
he was the love of my life
he i mean just goes on and on about how
wonderful he was and all this stuff and
she was like we had just graduated high
school
um i we were gonna get married all this
stuff i went to go live with my dad in
another town
um i come back months later and
you know your dad had gotten another
woman pregnant which is my my mom she
was right with me yeah she was like i
was devastated i was you know and i'm
reading this thinking
what the [ __ ]
and she gets into it she's like i just
want to let you know i just um listened
to your podcast on the honeydew and i am
so [ __ ] mad at your father because
the man i dated
all those decades ago would have never
[ __ ] um you know abandon his children
and and i'm disgusted with him and i
haven't talked to him since i think then
and she's like i'm so disappointed in
him and all this stuff and i'm like what
the [ __ ]
and i didn't respond to her yeah i
screenshotted it and sent it to in a
group message with my aunt
and is that his sister yes okay
my aunt and my two sisters
and i should have known not to [ __ ]
send it to my aunt that was dumb on my
part um i just wanted them to be like
what look look at what i just got does
your aunt know this woman or remember
this woman no no
oh they're best friends now
oh they're the best she told her to
subscribe to the [ __ ] honey dude
they are the best of friends my so i
just sent it to them being like dude
look at what i just over this text
this brought them together
oh my aunt's asking me a million
questions
who
i need to ask in timelines she's and
starts investigating and she was like i
found i just found her on facebook and
i'm like gala please do not message this
lady do please don't you know long story
short oh they've become best friends
they talk all the time
um
my
the lady i can't remember her name you
know if um that lady reached out to my
dad oh she did too
and i think it was so she hit you up
she's best friends with your aunt and
now she's hitting that up she's going
all through the family huh
she i can't remember what she did first
she either texted him first somehow got
his phone number probably from my aunt
holy [ __ ] i just put too much i was
gonna i was just about to ask you did
she reach out before or after becoming
friends with your aunt after
and she messaged my dad on um facebook
and said um basically i'm disappointed
in you
um those girls are great girls and
you're basically you're missing out on
like having a relationship with your
kids like you know i would have never
thought you would do something like this
type of thing
he left her on red
you think he read it and then put it
back on red though i don't
did you know for the for years i didn't
know that was a thing i would read
people's messages and then go back to
unread thinking that it wouldn't show
that i read it but i did did you know
that no that's a thing
god damn it okay anyway i go through
facebook and people sent me some weird
[ __ ] and i'm like and then i'll [ __ ]
mark it unread uh it still shows that
you read it son of a [ __ ] i know [ __ ]
facebook thank you tell me that i get
weird now i'm just not gonna answer
anybody
so anyway so then she gets a hold of his
number
text him i'm assuming the same thing i
don't know
um he changes his phone number
and i guarantee my his wife
you know i don't say too much uh she she
most definitely made him change his
phone number so that's what happened
after being on the honeydew
your aunt got a friend now they're
friends now and when my tickets went on
sale
uh my aunt texts me she's like could you
i can't remember the lady's name i'm
sorry you know she was like could you
get her tickets she wants she's wanting
to come to the whatever show and i'm
like yes i'll get her tickets like oh
she's part of family now now does your
dad have any more interaction with you
what's the extent of that oh i have not
spoken to him it's still nothing nothing
so you're finding out everything through
your aunt then about the texting and the
number and all that so he communicates
with her
very rarely sh uh i mean well i guess i
don't mean interrupts because you're
gonna yell at me for interrupting but i
guess what i'm really want to know is
he's that close
literally to being in contact with you
and just doesn't correct okay oh yeah oh
yeah we're facebook friends
that's about it
um
he um
yeah yeah and i don't post to facebook
but on the rare occasion i will he'll
like like a photo and that's about the
extent of it and listen he's probably
not gonna listen to this if he is and i
mean this truthfully he's a cool [ __ ]
dude
coolest i think i said this last time he
is a cool dude
[ __ ] funny hilarious i just i don't
know i think i think his wife has a lot
to do with it with him not having a
relationship with us
um
but um there's a lot of men i would say
this about and i'm speaking from my
experience in my life that
have women and relatives told me well
his his wife and his wife and i'm like
listen he's a person too
he could tell his wife hey i'm going to
go visit these people if you don't want
to come
[ __ ] go to do do a spa day hang out
with your girls or whatever but i'm
going to go visit these people and then
i'll come back and you don't ever have
to have a relationship with them i'm not
asking you to like them right tolerate
them put up with them nothing but i'm
gonna go see him and just be cool with
that yeah oh he doesn't have balls i
guess i don't know yeah i know plenty of
those dudes yeah life that don't have
balls yep yeah um but cool dude no i
haven't spoke to him um in over two
years we had a little family get
together whenever i told you he asked me
for my autograph right for a friend for
a friend yeah um that was two three
years ago i haven't no we don't stop
nothing and do you know where he is yeah
he lives in sulfur oklahoma he's still
there in oklahoma do you roll through
anywhere near by on a show for that and
do you think if you do he'll hit you up
no we had i had shows in dallas last
year and it's about maybe an hour drive
for him and he didn't come and i'm dude
i'm so okay i'm to the point now
well i've always been too okay with that
i've always been to the point but like i
don't expect anything from him and i'm
good you know you can't because anything
you expect you don't get it you just get
pissed off at yourself you're like i
knew better right exactly yeah and i
never really had
a relationship with either of my parents
so i don't feel like i'm i don't feel
like i'm
missing out on anything because i never
had it was it your grandmom that was
your closest yeah right yeah
um yeah she i was kind of raised by both
of my grandmas
once passed away and one's still um
alive but i really don't speak to her
why is that
dude okay so
all right
okay so
this is gonna sound really mean whose
mom is this by the way my mom's mom
it's gonna sound really mean my dad's
side of the family are pretty normal
my mom's side of family
they're like
the white trash okay that's where i
that's like where i really get that you
know gotcha
because i may look normal i'm trashy as
[ __ ] just letting everybody know
um
so
how do i put this there's always been
issues with them and it's a very small
side of the family it's my grandma my
aunt
i have an uncle bo that lives in a
trailer behind my grandma's trailer
and he's never worked a day in his life
so when she says he's out back he's not
out there doing work or anything he's
out there living yeah he's out there
growing weed
and i'm trying to think i have a couple
cousins and that's i mean that's really
it on my mom's side um and growing up
it was always so i got taken away
um my mom lost custody when i was 12 and
we went to live with this grandma coors
late is back on the do y'all and i know
there's a lot going on out there work
friends family a million pressing social
issues and the feeling that you got to
be on 24 7. and sometimes you just need
a moment to turn off and hit reset and
that is when you reach for coors light
all right
you guys know i like light beer coors
lights my favorite you'll see me
drinking on this show here that's the
one for me there's only one light beer
for me and it's coors light and there's
only one light beer out there that's
literally made to chill coors light the
mountains on the bottles and the cans
even turn blue when your beer is cold
that way you always know when it's time
to chill when i need to take a second
for myself i reach for the beer that's
made to chill get coors light delivered
straight to your door with drizzly or
instacart by going to coorslight.com
honeydew all right listen to me you can
get coors light delivered on drizzly or
instacart all right go to coorslight.com
honeydew it's coming to your house y'all
coors brewing company golden colorado
celebrate responsibly whatever way you
challenge yourself there's no better way
to do it than with a pair of raycom
wireless earbuds in your ears raycon
wireless earbuds are the best way to
bring audio with you because no matter
how much you shake things up literally
no matter how much you shake things up
you know they won't fall out of your
ears their everyday earbuds look feel
and sound better than ever there's also
awareness mode now okay for when you
need to listen to your surroundings so
you can take raycons with you wherever
you go with optimized gel tips for the
perfect in-ear fit these earbuds are so
comfortable and they will not budge
trust me i take them everywhere i've put
them in and jumped up and down ran
around after the dog and my daughter
just to see if i could get them to come
out and they're not coming out all right
and raycons offers eight hours of
playing time and a 32 hour battery life
and they're priced just right you get
quality audio at half the price of other
premium audio brands it's no wonder
raycon's everyday earbuds have over 48
thousand five star reviews right now
honeydew listeners can get fifteen
percent off their raycon order at buy
raycon.com honeydew that's by raycon
dot com slash honeydew to save fifteen
percent off on your rate cons by
honeydew now let's get back to the duke
so tell me again maybe we talked about i
just don't remember why were you taken
away
um
my mom had got arrested
for
drugs i don't know she was always
getting arrested so i don't know what it
was for
um and she was going to be in jail for
longer than the usual night or two i
guess
the usual
and um
so my um uncle worked at the police
station
so he was like hey you know linda got
arrested like she's gonna be in here for
a while like someone needs to get the
girls
so my grandma went and picked us up and
was only supposed to be until she got
out and when she got out she was
supposed to do like
a short list of things you know to to
get us back because at that point we
were in state custody and she just never
came back
so all she had to do was this checklist
and she just didn't do it yup get a job
get a house or whatever get have
somewhere to stay and i think that was
it basics yeah and she just never came
back
but did she do those things
uh
i don't know so when you're with the
state where are you are you in an
orphanage are you in a home what at my
grandma's it was weird it was weird how
like i was uh like a ward of the state
from from 12
to 18. damn really til you were an adult
yes but i
lived with my grandma because she was
almost like i don't know um what do they
call them when you get like um
foster i guess so she technically had
like foster gosh
so it was good how they said they had
visits and they checked in and stuff
like that oh yes gotcha on a regular
basis you're with a family member yeah
is it just you
me and my two younger sisters all three
of you are with grandma
and we're a year apart so that's good
that you aren't split up i know good i
know
um so where was i going with this uh i
don't know what i was talking about we
were talking about you got taken we were
living with your grandma you don't talk
to your grandma anymore oh how okay how
about all this came about and she
she's always been a very difficult
person to be around
um you know growing up my
aunt and mom had always just complained
about how how it was hell
growing up with her it was hell you know
and then so i'm like great so now you
leave me here thanks you know i was fine
with her and i got along but her and my
middle sister fought a lot so she was
always difficult to be around um my aunt
our relationship was great when i was
real young
but towards about
junior high um it shifted
is this the same man we were talking
about earlier no okay different
different aunt
um
it shifted to where she was and i hate
to say this because because it sounds
really douchy of me
but like she was always just and i know
they're going to listen to this by the
way because they listen to everything
they watch everything i do or so i hear
um but i don't care i don't speak to
them um almost a jealousy
um i see so when i was 13 or 14
um she was with this guy
um and they were well into their 30s
late 30s at this point
and
it was summer it was hot and
we were in a single bed truck driving
into town
and she was in the middle he was driving
i was by the door and he had said
something along the lines of me having
nice legs
and she got pissed
and not in the sense okay i have a 12
year old niece if i'm dating a guy and
he says something sexual about i'm i'm
[ __ ]
oh no she didn't get mad at him she got
mad at me you oh yeah um she said
something along the lines of like
well
i've got better legs something like that
and he was like oh no you don't
like first of all you're 13. and he's
arguing with her about it
so i think then on
a
switch flipped with her and me
and she has never ever ever been happy
for anything i've ever done
and it's almost she's almost like rolled
that over into my grandma
so
they're the type of people that
they
want you to live how they live if if you
do good for yourself then you're autumn
oh you think you're better than me
because you got out of love county
oklahoma
type of thing oh you think you're better
than me because you're like that's
that's been the dynamic of them and me
and my sisters
our whole lives
so and you know my grandma raised all of
her kids kids
because they turned out shitty so she
had to raise all their kids
and i just remember being i i remember
being young and being like this ain't
for me
this is not gonna be my life you know
and oh when we you know moved and got
jobs and graduated there was never any
congratulations it was always just
bitter
like why like they actively
like say things to you message you or
not say things
you know type of thing
um
and i can't remember this was um maybe
three years back i had done something
and i came here what it was it was
something big for me and beth my
youngest youngest sister was back home i
hadn't been back in years and she had
went home and it was my aunt and my
grandma and she had said oh did you guys
like chelsea's
doing this or something and they like
were like
i don't care type of thing and she was
like
and they got into a fight over it she
was like how can you not be why are you
never happy for
especially me but why are you never
happy for any of us and they were just
like just they're just bitter and
they're just sour and it's just it's a
really toxic
um
relationship and then yeah a few years
ago i was like
i'm good
i'm good it was causing more
sure more you know
than anything anxiety yeah oh the
happier we were in life and the more we
did successfully not just successful
financially but just success anything
successful that made us happy or
anything they the
the more they pulled back the more they
don't have anything to do with us
because they thought
oh y'all are out in california
living living your life and being happy
and you think you're better than us
although we've never given any incentive
that out that we've ever thought we were
better than anyone that's just on them
right that's their insecurities and i
really tried to make
you know the relationship work with my
grandma
she's never been in good health my whole
life
and um i got to a point where i was like
i'm you know
i'm
good
it was more toxic than anything
i did a vlog a couple years ago where um
i went back home and kind of showed my
hometown and stuff
and uh showed the trailer i grew up in
and stuff and
oh that's how i knew they were watching
everything i i saw
oh my grandma
um because at that time my younger
sister still tr tried to keep
um a relationship with my grandma so she
would call her on occasion
my grandma did not return her call for
months really oh after that
and there was nothing in this vlog that
it was a great vlog
and um
so finally beth left a voicemail and she
was like what the f why are you not
returning my are you okay like i can't
get a hold of anyone
my grandma finally called back and um
basically just accused us of making fun
of her
and we were like what are you like she
doesn't understand what i do she doesn't
understand the internet she doesn't
understand anything
um
and she was like you showed the trailer
like it was just very
my aunt i'm sure had showed her and
talked [ __ ] and got into her head and
that's when i was like um yeah we're
done
we don't speak
at all at all at all with my two younger
sister nothing we don't we don't we
don't speak to that side of the family
anymore and you know small small amount
of people but we're just
way too toxic
that's it you gotta cut way too toxic
yeah goddamn life and just people that
aren't
i mean i'm not saying you need praise
from people but just i'm not even asking
you to support me but could you be happy
oh could you be happy that i'm not
bumming money from you yes could you be
happy that i ain't laying on your
[ __ ] couch yeah would you be
happy you don't have to field calls from
me bitching every goddamn day about i
don't have the money and i could use
something from you and the life ain't
fair i mean come on how about a little
bit of happiness for my happiness so i'm
not bugging you i think that's what they
want
honestly
they're those type of people so and and
it's it's a bummer because my aunt is
once again she's so cool i remember like
growing up she was the cool aunt she was
the fun aunt oh me and her were so close
growing up like we you know she when i
was about
we had first gone to lit live with them
so i was probably 12 13. might have been
14. we were at the lake one day and she
was like
oh this is like a core memory you know
she came to me and she was like chelsea
you know something she goes
if anyone
in this family
is ever going to make something of
themselves it's going to be you
she knew she was like if anyone is gonna
get out of here
and and do something it's gonna be you
and i that's
[ __ ] stuck with me dude that i really
think that her having that just telling
me that
[ __ ] pushed my ass yeah
and she does she doesn't even understand
that she doesn't even know that but then
when i do
she gets
upset very weird
very weird situation very weird people
gonna say it it does make you wonder if
someone had said that same thing to her
when she was younger and never did and
regretted it and then you did now she
regrets you for getting the [ __ ] out i
mean you know they all wish they could
be you
they all wish they could be in these
videos with you they all wish they could
be doing what you're doing and they
can't so some
support you and they're happy with what
they're doing so i know plenty of people
are like yeah i know what you do i would
never [ __ ] want to do that doesn't
even interest me but good for you
nothing wrong with that either because
you're doing what makes you happy yeah
that's it
yeah and they're not happy people oh
they're not happy no no that's what then
that's what my that's what my sister
maggie says she's like chelsea they're
just
not happy people they're miserable and
to see someone
who came from we both came from the same
[ __ ]
to see someone that's doing something
it it it eats them alive yeah instead of
being empowering it it [ __ ] eats them
alive yeah it's horrible and i feel bad
you know right because you're a good
person yeah i feel like damn like we
could just have a wonderful relationship
could you know but it's that's just not
the way i
i'll only try for so long and then i'm
like
this is not
not good for me gotta go so now you're
getting ready to go on a big tour
you come from i mean listen let's talk
we talk about highlighting low light you
go from a war to the [ __ ] state
yeah to selling out theaters around the
united states how does that feel
dude i just got butterflies in my
stomach when you said that doesn't feel
real first off i get it i feel like
i'm like gonna wake up and be like whoa
that was the wildest [ __ ] dream dude
doesn't feel real and i feel like
almost like
how do i explain this i've always been a
super confident person i've always been
a super secure person but when it comes
to this
comedy stand up everything
i'm like
whoa
why me should i be i can't be
why am i do it like
this doesn't feel like i don't know what
i'm doing
type of thing and i can sit here and
easily sit across from me and say and
why not you but i get it because i've
been in the same i look i'm not selling
theaters i'm gonna get there but yeah
but i get it yeah it's easy to sit in my
seat and tell you all these things and
then versus telling myself those i try i
try to look in the mirror and say
positive [ __ ] if i'm gonna say anything
instead of just beating myself up for
the [ __ ] day you know so
talk to me about let's talk about
because i had andrew santino on here we
talked about the pressures of of selling
out theaters
because theater's not
it's not the comedy club is at least a
place in spot where you in town excuse
me where you're like let's go down that
spot and see some comedy yeah the
theater is you gotta look and see what
the [ __ ] because it's musical acts it's
ballets it's everything rolling through
that [ __ ] thing yeah so
where's your anxiety level right now
you're doing good you already sold out a
lot of your shows thank you you did
for me it's like
it's the pressure because i'm i get so
many dms from people being like
chelsea like i've i hired a babysitter i
took off work we're driving six hours
um we got a hotel for the weekend
i saved up i've been saving up for
months to come see you and i'm like
like
damn i gotta go out there
and give it my [ __ ] all right for
this every night
that's the weirdest
most intense
scariest but yet best feeling in the
world it cannot even be described i mean
you know but it's like
that's that for me that's where i'm like
oh my god i want every single person to
have a good time well you said you came
to riverside you messaged me after and
did not [ __ ] hit me up when i'm out
there with segora which i would love to
hang out with you i'm sorry but what is
it like because i know when i'm with tom
when he goes up i usually go smoke a
joint in the bowels of the theater and
then i usually like to walk to the top
back somewhere so i can see what it
looks like because
i don't turn around much in my act if at
all and i don't see
that backdrop i see this backdrop you
know so you being there and watching
that have you performed in a theater
that big yet one time i opened for
whitney cummings in vegas like
a month ago two months ago yeah a couple
months ago
and um she asked me she called me up and
asked me to open for her and my initial
because i've only done comedy clubs
and my initial which scares me by the
way 200 people i'm terrified
and
my first reaction was no no i'm not
gonna go in front of a thousand two
thousand i've never no
and then my mind was like chelsea you
have to [ __ ] do this
just say yes just rip the band-aid just
do it i'm scared of everything by the
way like tom called me this year and
goes do you want to do an arena and i
was like oh yeah i want to do an arena
but i don't want to do a goddamn room no
but i want to do you know what i mean
yeah when it comes to this business i
get nervous about everything and i've
never gotten nervous about anything else
in my life when i do a podcast right
before we film a podcast i was like i'm
nervous you are nervous although i've
been on here before and i know you like
and you do your own yeah i have my own
[ __ ] podcast it's i get nervous for
podcasts i get nervous for meetings i
get nervous for i
everything
so
but my thing is it doesn't matter how
nervous i am just [ __ ] do it
yes just
pretend you're not scared that's what i
do a lot i just have to pretend i'm not
scared and then i go and i [ __ ] crush
whatever i do yeah you do um like
roaches and [ __ ] with your teeth exactly
that's still a lot of fun it was what
was it was it a roach it was a plastic
wrote but it was a roach though right
that i got on amazon and i've tied it
with fishing wire it makes me [ __ ]
lame every time you pulverize and i knew
that would nobody had to be bruised oh
no these things can take a pounding
that's not trying to tell my daughter
these oh 100 percent those are veterans
people are like oh that must have hurt
i'm like that was [ __ ] nothing
no if you don't know what we're talking
about tell them
i did a i did a a video a few months
back trailer trash trailer trash tammy
shirt wanted to wear myself today a
calendar that would probably put my
daughter in therapy
i will be circling
i was like man i want to do i want to do
a video i was touring and i hadn't
really put out a lot of content because
i was busy i want to do a video i want
to do something that i know is going to
do well i go titty stuff always does
well for me i was like what could i do
that's going to be like
i don't know slapping something with my
titty doing something like that and i
was like dude i'm sitting at a
restaurant as trailer attached tammy
roach goes across the table she's
[ __ ] beating that i go i go this is
going viral
get on amazon
plastic roaches fishing wire
we went to abuelos in oklahoma city
before a show
the music was so loud that they knew who
i were and i was like hey can you all
turn to off the music i want to film a
video they're like yeah turned off the
one take
one
i wore no bra libby was sitting over
there and i go yeah all i'm gonna need
to do is pull that wire real slow for me
one take i'm set they're eating chips i
see that thing just boom
it's probably one of my favorite videos
it's fantastic yeah yeah this man i have
never seen somebody pulverize something
with a titty like
everyone's like oh my god your t is your
titty okay i'm like dude yes
i do that [ __ ] daily
i'll just [ __ ] slap people with my
tits dude in the head like that's just
you know just for fun mm-hmm
um
yeah
we went off track where was i going i
don't remember where we were from the
titties i know i don't know what i was
talking about but um
we're talking about theaters and and
performing and performances
what we do
like what to prepare do what we do for
the so
you've got
so many shows sold out already
and you've never done the whitney show
is the first time you've done this so
you still have yet to do an hour in
front of a oh i only have like a 40 45
minute set and and
yeah but if you're killing it with that
time you take those let those laughs
that you'll be up there yeah yeah what's
um when is the actual first date
april 15th in denver colorado all right
kicking off in denver yeah yeah that's a
great city it's a great comedy town too
like they love comedy there i'm very
excited that's a good one um and um gosh
we're going all over
um i'm super pumped about this because
we're doing like new cities we haven't
gone to
and um
i don't know we get we get to the venues
super early because we like to like just
chill and my sister runs our merch booth
so it takes her [ __ ] hours to set
that up
um
and i just like to sit backstage kind of
being all nervous for a few hours and
then
and then go out there and crush dude
yeah
yeah you're a [ __ ] killer i've been
talking about the how to buy a home
podcast for a while host david cedoni
has been helping first-time homebuyers
figure out how to buy a house in every
kind of real estate market imaginable
and he can help you especially in this
crazy market david answers questions
like what if i'm not ready yet and how
do i even start there are stories from
other honeydew listeners who made it
happen check out the interview with
randy he's a honeydew listener a year
ago randy had no job zero credit and the
bank denied his home loan then he heard
about how to buy a home contacted dave
and now he's closed on a two hundred
thousand dollar three-bedroom home with
a two-car garage and a huge basement on
a half acre david can help you no matter
what stage you're in he can even connect
you with a great realtor in your area
don't rely on old information when it
comes to buying a home get the latest on
the how to buy home podcast and make
this the last year you rent listen to
the how to buy home podcast today find
how to buy a home on youtube and where
you listen to podcasts athletic greens
is the health and wellness company that
makes comprehensive daily nutrition
really really simple with so many
stressors in life it's difficult to
maintain effective nutritional habits
and give our bodies the nutrients it
needs to thrive i take athletic greens
every day i got a little pouch and my
scoop boom in my water i'm out the door
all right take it when i travel it's
easy to be healthy when you've got it
right there in your hands y'all as the
research changes so does ag-1 while most
nutritional products that come to market
never evolve athletic greens continues
to obsessively improve ag-1 based on the
latest research producing 53
improvements over the last decade and
counting they invest in high quality and
reputable sources of each ingredient and
go above and beyond in third party
testing to ensure their customers
continue to receive the highest quality
and best daily nutritional habits on the
planet it's lifestyle friendly so
whether you're eating keto paleo vegan
dairy-free or gluten-free and it
contains less than one gram of added
sugar no gmos no nasty chemicals or
artificial anything while keeping it
tasting good to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you an immune
supporting free one year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com honeydew today again
simply visit athleticgreens.com
honeydew to take control of your health
and give a g one a try now let's get
back to the duke all right so let's talk
about some more
this is an interesting i don't get to
talk about low lights of this uh
industry too often but there's a
weirdness that you have so you had your
instagram taken down how many followers
did you have i had uh 1.1 million jesus
yeah and they took it down now here's
the thing about something like that
it's that's a [ __ ] big deal to lose
that audience when you're about to
promote a theater [ __ ] tour yeah when
you're about to go out and yourself
basically you're self-promoting
everything you're doing it all yourself
so what happened and and where are you
at with that right now
oh lord so i've been shadow banned
hardcore for
once i hit a million they've pretty much
halted my [ __ ] i haven't gained any
followers in two years really although
my other platforms
have gained um although my career has
taken off um they've really have not let
me gained followers in two years
um
everything gets taken down that i post i
mean i've posted like i was cooking eggs
one day
and just did a video of frying the eggs
put an aerosmith song on it you know got
taken down for soliciting sex
like okay what were you wearing no it
was the just the eggs oh close up on the
egg no yep
you know i've done a q a where somebody
was like what was your softball number
in college and i was like number nine
got taken down for soliciting sex and
nudity i'm like really answering them
with the number so my [ __ ] gets taken
down like
i would don't even have to post anything
that's even remotely worth taking down
and they'll take it down
so they've been saying for two years
your account may delete it may be
deleted your account may be deleted
um so a few months ago it got deleted
well i got it back
and then a month later is when it got
deleted again oh it got deleted twice oh
i didn't know that it got deleted i'm
like what the [ __ ] for what so my
management was on it i got it back
within like two weeks pretty much
instagram was like
we don't know
we're sorry type of thing
like jesus christ so then um it happened
again i've had it it's been almost two
months now since it got deleted
um and
instagram pretty much said
we've investigated it and
she violated too many community
guidelines and her um we're not giving
her account back and it's like here's
the deal
i'm not like butt hurt about
i lost a million followers because like
this is gonna sound cocky but that'll be
back
my you know my
my platforms everywhere else are growing
and strong like people will realize hey
i haven't seen her instagram then it
that's fine i'm pissed that i lost all
the content yeah 13 years that's a lot
of work of content free work
13 years of content
and i'm pissed at just the principle of
like whoa dude i mean i see tits and ass
on instagram all day
all [ __ ] day it's suggested to me in
my reels often and that's fine yeah
that's fine but if i post and i'm titty
killing a roach you're [ __ ] getting
flagged
with a full t-shirt on yeah
i have been it's just it's
it's well and i've really
really toned it down
the last
year
i mean there's stuff i've wanted to put
and thank god for only fans that's why i
post that [ __ ] to only fans we i do
vlogs and
all types like the [ __ ] that i can't
post anywhere else is i slap it on there
but damn you want to be able to just
post something to instagram without so
i've really had to water myself down
i've really had they won't allow tammy
to have a cigarette anymore no on
instagram
everywhere everything is demonetized
people like what happened to tammy's
cigarette i'm like well if i want to
make money it's gotta
take the back murder
um just everything it's just the
censorship is just unbelievable so the
instagram's gone i've got a backup you
know that it's growing what already
what how many followers all right like
170 000 yeah yeah that's ridiculous yeah
so um it's fine it'll be back and how do
you do let me ask you this i want to
know how you deal with trolls because i
get nonstop [ __ ] about you know oh
well some people mostly it's my laugh
but i'll get a lot of people
i've seen comments and i love your
laughter what the [ __ ] people hit on i
mean i get it though i get why someone
could be like shut the [ __ ] up but
that's not the only thing i get i get
you know i get a lot of [ __ ]
but what i want to know is how you deal
with trolls like that like you're listen
you are putting your body out there okay
and
i mean literally you put your titties
out
there just started putting my ass out
there did you really this year yeah how
do you deal with the trolls who go after
you because
i mean i know what i get i can't imagine
what you must [ __ ] get on a daily
basis
you're gonna hate me you get all love
yeah [ __ ] yeah do you really i've i
don't get
i don't get hate you don't get any
trolls very rare that is rare
for any human to get it very rare but
see maybe there's something to that then
because you attack what they would go
after anyway yeah make fun of all the
[ __ ] trashy fun parts that they would
[ __ ] on you for anyway
yeah i remember when we did the craft
fees podcast we i used to say you know i
something to the effect of i said you
know give us a five star review and i
don't remember if i said you know don't
write [ __ ] the crab feast and then five
stars or if you you could say i don't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] crafty's five stars
and it became this thing of love like
you guys suck you're the worst [ __ ]
crab feast five stars so
at that point once the haters jumped in
you couldn't touch the [ __ ] the people
who loved us were saying it it would
just be [ __ ] like not for me you know
what i mean like yeah who gives a [ __ ]
mm-hmm so good for you you get
positivity they're very yeah very and
and if i do get hate it's always on
facebook it's never on any other
platform is that right facebook is like
where the yeah and it's usually older
people who have no idea what's going on
you know
like just an old lady who's like [ __ ]
80s she'll be like cover up this isn't
it you know but it's like in terms of
hate i mean i i've been i have lucked
out and maybe i'm not seeing it i don't
know but
it's i've never you would see it okay
you got enough [ __ ] followers
yeah
and and i handle all my [ __ ] comments
and everything so nobody else is on
there i
very rare well i get a hate comment
that's awesome once every couple months
i may see something
very rare so what makes you decide when
you wake up are you feeling a certain
way when you're doing a tami video
versus one of your glam shoots
so i'm telling you you are drop you go
from
greasy [ __ ] jack-in-the-box
drive-through cigarette barely hanging
in the lips yeah you drop dead [ __ ]
gorgeous thank you i don't even
i can't comprehend mentally your range
phenomenal
i'm either one or the other you are
stunning yeah thank you and then you go
to [ __ ] beating roaches up with your
titties yep and it takes me like
like five seconds to be one or the other
like there's no
no oh yeah oh yeah that makes me even
more a makeup wipe and just slick my
hair back and and i'm tammy in five five
seconds
um
i don't know the the
the um the dress-up stuff is fun what
i'm laughing about tammy because
the [ __ ] voice and the aggression and
the always moot the movement in there
the facial expression she always looks
like something stinks always always but
[ __ ]
um it's like it reminds me of jackie
gleason and smoking the band that when
he played cherokee for t justice and
everything was heartburn through the
whole thing it was always just
always just always already at a level
where something's disturbing them and
everything's all marty my annoyance is
already at eight you know what i'm
starting at eight yes but the l i talk
about the baltimore accent all the time
and it's uh somebody said it's a
non-binary accent because it could be
like this right here this accent here
this could be my aunt theresa or my
uncle
you know what i mean it's the same
[ __ ] voice yeah that's funny i love
that tammy voice you [ __ ] all of it
just though yep it's it's for me it's
like cocaine energy non-stop too for me
jamie's in the mannerisms it's all about
the mannerisms
i mean i could say something on stage
that's really not funny but if i just
give it just a just a tammy look yeah or
a rock or a
i'll just say something and it and i'll
kind of sit there after i'll kind of
look at the crowd and they'll just
[ __ ] just lose it you know it's for
her it's all about the mannerisms
so then how do you go into a shoot where
you
glam up and go so [ __ ] sexy i just
when did you start doing that um during
the beginning of the pandemic i had a
friend reach out and he was like he's
who is a makeup and hairstylist here in
l.a
and he was like chelsea like
you know everything's shut down we we
can't work um
but we still want to like have content
to put out to grow our [ __ ] he was like
you know like
we're trying to get some people if we
can do your hair and makeup and and just
in return you get pictures to post and i
was like yeah i you know wasn't doing
anything and i was like yeah let's do it
so we and my audience have has at that
point had never really seen me like that
you know i've always this is how i
always look had you
um
oh pro no
no
this is like as dressed up as i get day
to day
and um we did a shoot i can't remember
what the first shoot was we did a shoot
and uh loved it you know and i've always
been very comfortable in front of the
camera
video
pictures and most you know people aren't
they're kind of sh oh i'm [ __ ] like
you know i'm wishing i was yeah and um
we did the i posted the pictures and
most people loved it i got a couple like
who's this you know we want 10 you know
but i post both i'm
my whole online existence is not just
trailer trash tammy yeah i know and i
really want that's what i'm saying your
range is ridiculous thank you
um
and then i just kept it up so like and i
started using the pictures as like
promotion for stuff i had a shoot a
couple months ago we used it for the
tour poster like
and just when i have time
maybe every six months or so i'm like
hey let's do another shoot now do you
turn a switch in your head for something
that's sexy sexy and not as funny
or in your mind the whole time you're
doing those shoots are you thinking of
tammy [ __ ]
the whole time i'm doing the chelsea
sexy shoots am i thinking of tammy no no
nothing creeps in your mind to be funny
with that
no
no those are really easy for me i just
they're sexy as [ __ ] so where do you get
that
where do you get that confidence to get
in front of a camera and do that
and do it that [ __ ] good dude i well
you got to understand we'll take like a
thousand pictures and i'll get one
that's all you need okay one [ __ ]
good one that's all you need
you're seeing the best one out of eight
thousand shots
just know that
um no they're so fun dude and i just
it's just that's just like fun you know
and people oh my gosh people have
started being like you need to do a
chelsea calendar like that and i'm like
i don't know
i don't know about that because to me
okay
the the tani calendar is obviously
topless but it's funny
it's meant to be comedic yes okay
because my tits are not like your normal
calendar tits let's just try to tell my
daughter yeah you know they're not your
normal we should have started y'all
smaller yeah
so that so that calendar was my way of
like you know tammy's very um
cocky
and so that was my way of tammy thinking
she's hot enough to do a calendar
it's hilarious people [ __ ] out of
everything i do that is like the number
one
biggest thing i do people go nuts for it
and i don't know if i were to do a
calendar as chelsea to me and i and i
don't care girls that do
nudes whatever i'm not judging nothing
but to me that's where it's like i don't
know that's that's a little too much for
me why
i don't know
i don't know why would you allow
yourself to push yourself in the
boundaries comedically this way out of
your comfort zone but not the other way
don't know
never thought about it
i've just always shut that down to be
like chill if you're comfortable enough
to do the shoot just maybe not make a
calendar out of it or anything but yeah
oh i'll do a show oh yeah i'll do you're
also very body positive yeah why don't
well let me see not why don't i guess my
question is this all right first let's
go back to this when was the first time
you actually showed your tits on camera
for social media
you can keep your personal business to
yourself right oh no i've never like
they'll nothing will ever come back to
haunt me ever
all your titties are already out all my
titties are out if you google chelsea
and tits there's like dozens dude
i don't even give a [ __ ] there has to be
at least 36.
um
i think my first
tip
exposure to the public was my first
calendar and was that nerve-racking or
were you like i was terrified only
because i was scared it was gonna like
ruin my career
[ __ ] that shit's taken off with those
tips
we're making this [ __ ] famous
um oh i was terrified and i didn't even
go into it thinking it was going to be
topless that was a last-minute decision
um because i did i did a calendar the
year before but it was like a tammy sexy
calendar but everything was covered
and then people were like we want to see
tit and i was like i'm not down and then
last minute i was like you know what
[ __ ] it let's do this
and so nobody knew that it was going to
be topless oh you didn't tell oh man
hell yeah and greg didn't even know he's
not no
and uh i was like oh uh
by the way i'm the the calendar's gonna
be topless he's like oh okay i mean that
was it you know i didn't give a [ __ ]
but um oh ever since that first release
of tits
oh it's been on ever since you know yeah
um so off yeah exactly yeah exactly
um oh our only fans vlogs are all tits
they are it's all like us like doing
[ __ ] it's nothing like sexual it's us do
so we um to you it's not every dude
you're right
you're right most of my subscribers are
women are they i would say 90
that's huge all right i got a big
industrial
food scale
and me paige libby who's my friend who
opens for me and my two sisters we did a
vlog where we just weighed our tits
we weighed each tit and we we did a
guess on who how much we thought your
tit was going to weigh and then that's
your titties yeah
god how much was my okay okay i think
i'm wrong see if i can ballpark it i'm
not going to get sh am i guessing each
titty or am i guessing a combined weight
right now yes per
my
tip
weighs eight pounds and that's titty
private
i'ma go with nine and eight
whoa
whoa ryan
a nine pound tit
do you know how big that is so that's
the size of my dog
a nine pound tit
you have 18 pounds of titties
[Applause]
god that's a huge titty
that's a big [ __ ] tip
i would like to see you live on city
god
well you're how much of your titties
they're like three pounds each yeah
three to four i can't they weren't four
pounds
well i tell you what
maybe the cam rad's 15
those titties look bigger than that in
that counter
okay look at my my three pound tent and
quadruple that's a
a nine pound test right here
that's that's right 100
100
100
oh
holy [ __ ] see i'm an idiot i don't know
it's a huge titty
god
and then and then so i would flop my
head on i would flop my tit on on the
weight scale and it'd just go boom
and then paige puts her little tit on
and it doesn't even move
and she's got decent sized tits but just
the comparison to the
the clump and then
we were dying dude we were dying
and once your tits are out there it's
like well they're already out there
might as well just make have fun with it
you know so and people love td content
but you don't put your tits out on your
sexy shoots do you no i put them out in
a sexy way
because i feel like i don't know that
would almost be like
i don't know
i can't explain it like if i put them
out in a funny way it's just funny i put
out my sex away i'm like calm down you
know i don't know
i don't know people are begging for a
chelsea lynn calendar so i'm i don't
know
count me among them yeah i'll send you
one yeah keep that one for my daughter
i'll be the one telling my daughter hey
you need to put some [ __ ] in mine now
that one shot wouldn't want her the
teeny one's funny but no
she flipped through a couple of them
i won't know which one she saw i do tell
i'll ask her one just one she was
flipping through after a while i think
she saw that and thought there'd be
something else when she went and there
was she just said another tammy like
damn you please put another image oh my
god
hilarious
so [ __ ] funny dude
i love it tit content nine pound titty
nine wanted five can't you tell i have
no idea
a nine pound tit man right you couldn't
you could you could hurt yourself one
and nine oh my god that wrist up a
little bit holy [ __ ]
no i hope my tits never no they're
capped out and growing yeah the entities
ain't good they're kept
they're still growing no no they're done
growing you're done growing girl
yeah they're done
um
[Music]
can i ask you about marriage yeah you've
been married for how long now
since 2009
so
13 years 13 years we've been together
16. can i ask you how old you are i'm
34. you've been together for since you
were 18. yes i was i just turned 18.
whoa so the state handed you right over
to your husband
stop yes he's your [ __ ] problem holy
[ __ ]
never thought about that that's [ __ ]
funny
is that right though you went right from
that to yeah and you've been together
ever since yes my whole adult life
that's [ __ ] weird to think about
that's [ __ ] weird how about that yeah
i look back on like 16 that doesn't
that's your whole adult life that's
weird yeah that's really that's gonna be
a hell of a dude dude he's [ __ ]
yeah he's hilarious is he does he do
anything
no and every time i post him people just
love
they love greg content
um he's even like when we're with people
like i'm the quiet calm one and i'm not
quiet and calm he's just that [ __ ]
loud and crazy that it makes me look
quiet and calm yeah yeah he's a lot he's
a lot to be around sometimes i'm like
please i'm like
go to another room leave me alone he's a
lot you know what i mean love him to
death but um yeah he's definitely
crazier than me he doesn't do any social
media but what a wild ride for [ __ ]
two kids it was he was 18 also no he's
uh four years older than me so he was
like
yeah yeah yeah
wow
yeah
to go from like
you know
i was talking to him not too long ago
i'm like greg
like
who would have thought
when we first got [ __ ] married
and i was working at the mall
and we were living in richardson texas
oh
north park mall in dallas what store
things remembered
i got some shitty grave there back in
the day
stop
that was the place you went yeah people
get like a little jewelry box with like
chelsea we love your nine-pound titties
yeah give it to you yeah yeah i would do
the engraving things remember i totally
know things remember yeah
[ __ ] hated it i'd rather work in the
food industry than the than the sales
yeah
did you ever [ __ ] up someone's [ __ ] oh
all the time yeah all the time
um what did he come into things
remembered for
is that how you met and no one call it
we met in college on facebook
when facebook was like
first launched and it was just for
college kids
oh wow you did that just back then i i
only knew that because of the movie i
didn't know it was just this college
thing at first oh you had to have a
college um uh email to get a facebook a
regular email would not work i didn't
know that okay
you got to be like approved to only
college kids are on it
and uh just came out there was no social
media i mean this was like fresh yeah
for real and somehow we met on facebook
and um yeah that that's how we met
so he's watched you go from literally
none of this tammy stuff all the way to
now that's what i was telling i was like
dude how crazy is this like we couldn't
afford to go to applebee's
we were just working regular i go who
would have [ __ ]
thought and he was like it's wild
chelsea i would have never i would have
never thought this
ever but when we moved to california
um we've been in california almost nine
years now eight nine years and i didn't
want to move that was from texas yeah
okay i was pissed why just my sisters
were in
back home and i was like what are we
moving to california for like this is
you know
and um i just started social media i
think i had like a thousand followers
which to me was
i was like a thousand followers i just
started the tami stuff
and he was like well look at this way
we'll be out in california you'll be
we'll be close to la like you can go
after your dreams you know and i was
like
you kind of sold me on that i was like
all right like let's
let's go otherwise i would have never
who know dude i don't know even with the
social media stuff i think about that
all the time i'm like who if we stayed
there would i still be even doing this
don't know
don't know it's wild to think about
yeah what happens when you chase your
dreams yeah that's what happens yeah you
might just [ __ ]
make it come true yeah yeah i know i
know
he's been yeah we've been together so
long it's like [ __ ] he's been there
since the very beginning
wild
that's i'm so proud of you thank you
[ __ ] yeah thank you i love that you're
selling out theaters right now now let
me ask you this so even still all that
no nothing from dad no nothing
no no and i don't know if he's ever been
to a show and just not told you or oh he
would oh oh he totally would have told
he would probably ask my aunt for gas
money or something like i would have
known
i got to get the tip yeah i would have
known has he been to was he at a show i
don't i've got his name no he isn't he
no he's never been to a show
no
no man that is wild
you have lived a wild [ __ ] life young
lady dude i feel like it you have i feel
like it and it's just getting started
that's the other thing
all this time to just get started crazy
but i'm about to be 35 i'll be 35 in
august
and i'm first off i'm like whoa i just
turned 25
where's where's the last 10 years been
right
35 ryan i know it 10 years boom like
that for real a blink it's wild
i'm like i liter i started the whole
social i started all this when i was 26.
26. my name's stark comedy talks 27.
really
wow what'd you do before then were you
in la i st i did improv in la when i
first got here for a year and then i did
like the groundlings and [ __ ] like that
and then i went in to stand up wow but
before that i was all working and
putting myself through college and just
getting my feet under me from you know
all the death and [ __ ] that yeah took
place wow but look at you yeah
yeah some girl i'm proud of you i really
am proud thank you you've already come
such a long way since the last time we
had you here which feels like [ __ ]
forever we had a pandemic in the middle
of it that's how long it's been yeah
thank you again for coming back thank
you for being so sweet um thank you for
ruining my daughter's childhood
and uh will you please promote
everything again please all of it first
off real quick i will but it's like
little kids get into playboys yours got
into a tammy calendar she did
um
first time she sees somebody's titties
she's gonna be like that ain't nothing
you need to put those little [ __ ]
mosquito bites away [ __ ]
um my best friend and i have a podcast
called the viral podcast it is growing
like [ __ ] wildfire it's been so much
fun to do it's called the viral podcast
check it out um
we just take we basically take uh
questions from callers um and they'll
we can get deep we'll we talk a lot
about funny stuff they'll call in and
tell us wild [ __ ] that's happened to
them and it gets crazy over there
um chelsea lynn on all across all
socials i'm verified you'll find me look
for that blue check mark and yeah
i love it i love you too thank you for
making time for us today you're the [ __ ]
thank you so much as always ryan sickler
on all social media ryan sickler.com
we'll talk to y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you